دعني أسألك عن علاقتك
مع دونالد ترامب كما يقول والآن
بعد أن اختلقك أو بعد التغريدة
التي قال إن لديك الكثير من القواسم المشتركة وأنا
أتساءل ما هذا لأنه يصف
نفسه بأنه قومي ويعتمد على هؤلاء
الشعبويين  تصف
نفسك كثيرًا كواحد من أكبر
المعارضين لقوى
القومية والشعبوية هذه ، فما الذي تعتقد
أنه مشترك بينكما على
الأرجح حقيقة أن كلاً منا
خارج عن السياسيين الكلاسيكيين الذي
يمكنني قوله وأنك وصلت سابقًا
من الشركة  جانبًا ، لم يكن مرشحًا
مفضلًا وكان مرشحًا غير متوقع
وكنت في
نفس الموقف إلى حد كبير في فرنسا ربما
لأننا متحالفون جدًا في
الحرب ضد الإرهاب ونعمل
معًا بشكل وثيق جدًا باتباع هذا
الخط ونعرف أين نختلف  ونحن
واضحون جدًا في ذلك بشأن
المناخ بشأن التجارة والتعددية ،
لكننا نعمل معًا بشكل جيد للغاية لأن
لدينا مناقشات منتظمة
ومباشرة للغاية.  من حقك أن أقول
إنني وطني وأؤمن بحقيقة أن
شعبنا مهم جدًا
وأن وجود شعب فرنسي يختلف
عن الشعب الألماني ، فأنا لست
مؤمنًا بنوع من العولمة دون أي
تمايز على ما أعتقد  ليس
الأمر متسقًا
للغاية ، وهو أمر يجعل شعبنا متوترًا للغاية ،
لكنني لست قومياً ،
وهو أمر مختلف تمامًا بالنسبة لي عن
كوني وطني ،
فأنا أدافع عن شعبي.  أعتقد أن
لدينا هوية قوية ولكنني
مؤمن قوي بالتعاون بين
الشعوب المختلفة وأنا
مؤمن قوي بحقيقة أن هذا
التعاون مفيد للجميع
حيث يعتمد القوميون أحيانًا
على نهج أحادي الجانب
.  قانون الأقوى الذي
ليس من
السذاجة أنني ربما كل الاختلاف